foreign
all right welcome to this meeting of
baylor district council cabinet i'm
councillor john ward leader of baber
district council and i'll be chairing
this meeting may i remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
you maintain social distancing from all
other persons whilst in the chamber and
in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so and that use the hand sanitizer
and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
finally we will be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern.gov app so
please members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council until the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph will broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
now now move on to the agenda
item one apologies for absence
sorry chad
we have received apologies from
councillor mccraw and councillor davis
and also we received apologies for the
assistant director for economic
development and regeneration and the
assistant director for environment and
commercial partnership is here instead
thank you
item 2 to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members are there any declarations
okay
item three paper bca 2146 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on
the 7th of march
so
they're on pages 5 to 12 of your agenda
pack
um does anyone have any comments on
these meeting minutes i'll just go
through page five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven
and twelve is a blank page actually so
um
no comments on the minutes
in which case
um
may i have a proposal for minutes
councillor arthy and as secondary
councillor barrett
so now we'll conduct the electronic vote
for these minutes
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app
all right
sorry were you taking both of the
minutes together for that vote
council melvisi
are you able to
okay
sorry it's just come through now thank
you that is eight votes for chair
item 4 paper bca 2147 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 7th
of february 2022. if you remember we um
had to postpone the confirmation of
these minutes last month
so they're on pages 13 to 21 of your
agenda pack
um
page 13
page council busby
it was resolved
a bit of a spelling mistake there okay
thank you
thank you castle busby
page 14
and finally 21.
there are no comments then may i have a
proposal please for these minutes
counselor barrett and seconder
casarathi thank you
will now conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is not in
progress
counselor halt
are you able to vote
okay
[Music]
just come through thank you very much uh
that is uh eight votes for thank you
so council busby did you have a question
because you've we've already had a
chance to look through the the content
of these yeah i just wanted to just
clarify
finally
on 81.5
and 81.6
sorry is bellevue
implies that we're going to spend 2
million plus
the receipts of 1.1 million on bellevue
so the total spend on bellevue will be
3.1 million pounds
can i just confirm that that's what
we're aiming to do
um
we have actually
approved and voted on these minutes now
i think if we can if we can pick up the
subject of bellevue at a later date
because um
uh
to be able to answer that question
[Music]
now
it wouldn't do it justice because it
needs to set it in the context of
everything we're proposing to do there
so i'd rather pick that up at another
time
but uh the only thing i'll say now at
the moment that
the the capital expenditure is a is a
provision it's not
it's not a commitment
but um we'll we'll talk about bellevue
another time
okay uh so moving on then
um item five to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
castle's petition scheme
non-deceived item six questions by
councillors non-received chair
item seven matters referred by the
overview scrutiny or joint order
standards committees there are no such
matters referred chair thank you
and item a forthcoming decisions list
members you've had a chance to look at
that does anyone have any comments on
the forthcoming decisions list
and
the only one that i would want to make
is we do have a very
busy
schedule for cabinet in in june it's
going to be a very interesting meeting
um
and
it's probably going to be quite a
lengthy one but um
so i hope everyone will be able to turn
up for the june cabinet meeting
what date in june um it is the sixth of
june
okay so moving on then item nine paper
bca2148
homes england
2021-22 compliance audit program in
respect of the road brantham development
i'll now invite the cabinet member for
housing to introduce this report
so council osborne
thank you mr chairman
i am pleased to introduce this report in
respect of the homes england compliance
audit of our development of affordable
housing at ipswich road in brampton and
particularly pleased to report that
holmes england confirmed the scheme had
received a green compliance status with
no breaches
homes england identified proportion of
schemes receiving their funding to audit
each year to ensure that schemes are
being delivered in accordance with the
funding requirements and delivering good
value for money
this scheme in brampton delivered nine
new homes with 630 000
of homes england funding and completed
in january 2022 delivering much-needed
affordable homes to our residents
homes england require formal
acknowledgement from baber district
council that the audit has been received
from homes england hence reporting this
to cabinet today i'd be happy to take
any questions in this regard and our
officer hazel's here to also answer any
questions mr chairman i will now propose
approval to the recommendations outlined
in this report and i would ask for a
seconder please
thank you council oswald may have a
second castle busby
okay um so
questions members of the cabinet uh does
anyone have any questions on this
no
do any other counselors here have any
questions
right um we'll move into debate uh so
does anyone wish to open the debate on
this
council osborne
thank you mr chairman you wouldn't
expect anything else would you um i'd
just like to say um you know this
development is an exemplar of really
good design and it's the one as is the
one recently completed in shockley
the design is you drive up to it and uh
you wouldn't know it was social housing
it's fantastic it just fits in with the
street scene completely
and these developments demonstrate a
creative approach to finding ways to
build our own homes by demolishing
redundant void properties and building
on the same site new homes
our way of compensating for lack of
available land which is an issue at the
moment preventing us from building our
own homes thank you mr chairman
thank you council osborne and i must say
um
if council mccraw uh were here the the
local member for brantham i know that he
would uh be singing the praises of this
development is excellent and uh the fact
that it's got a green rating is um is
testament to uh
the quality of that
um does anyone else wish to say anything
uh council busby
just to say that it's really
the size of this scheme
makes it acceptable to most villages
parishes whatever because it's it's not
out of proportion to
the village itself it's only when we get
these big three 400 500
developments where
it's totally out of proportion that
people get upset i think we should be
bearing in mind we've got to look at the
local plan again we should be looking at
this kind of scale development as much
as we can
yeah yes i i think um we'll leave that
up to the uh planning policy team and
and
the review of the site allocations but
um
in terms of
something this size
nine social rented homes uh development
of nine
depending on the type or the size of the
the community um
different sizes schemes can can fit in i
think it's it's not um it doesn't have
to be this small for everywhere
no and you could also have more than one
of these schemes
okay does anyone else wish to uh
to say anything
in which case we'll move to the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
chair that is vote eight votes four and
that's carried
moving on item ten paper bca2149
the council tax energy rebate for
2022-23
i'll now invite the cabinet member for
finance to introduce the report
councillor barrett
uh thank you chairman um yes this report
is brought to you
for us to uh authorize the assistant
director of corporate resources uh in
consultation with myself to um
uh be able to offer discretionary
payments um from a small fund uh over
and above the 150 pounds which has been
uh designated by the government in their
uh fuel support payment
um this is uh
obviously uh
a to a to d and then there's a small
discretionary
amount and that has to be decided um and
we'd like to this is before you to give
the discretionary payment option to the
assistant director
and that's recommendation 3.1 and 3.2
within your report and i propose that if
i could have a second to please
thank you councillor barrett may i have
a second uh
well i'd be happy to second that
right are there any questions members
counselorathy
yeah i'm not sure if it's a a question
or debate but i'll start it with a
question
and that's about the recommendation that
you've just seconded
and options one and two
um because i feel that the discretionary
element
should um come back to cabinet
for consideration and approval
so i don't think that's actually the
recommendation that's just been moved is
it
no
no so is that an amendment then uh it
would have to be but can we leave it to
the debate section and then get up there
i just want to go through any questions
before we move into debate because i i
know that probably one of two things
that people wish to comment on later
councillor busby
section 4.1
the background
it says the funding is due to be paid on
the 30th of march
uh then the next 4.2 it says it should
be paid as soon as possible from april
are we
the funding that's due to be paid on the
30th of march is that from the
government to us
if not it doesn't doesn't stack up with
the sentence below
i think that is the case catherine is
that that is yeah that's the case yes is
is there any significance in the fact
that one's in one tax year and one's
then the other
we're getting it in on tax year one and
paying out in tax year two
no we'll probably have to account for it
in 21 22 because we've received it but
we'll just carry it forward and then pay
out in 21 in 22 23 so yeah
whether the government had got the money
allocated and they needed to get it out
the door for the end of the year i don't
know
so have we received it
i'm pretty sure we have yes
i would double check but i'm pretty sure
we did
any other questions
cancer osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah with
the discretion what's the extent of the
discretion we can go to
please
thank you chair um the original guidance
was payments of 150 pounds but they've
since amended the guidance to say you
could use discretion to top up
people that have already had 150 pounds
so for instance your ctr cases in a to d
it's your choice if you wanted to then
give them a top-up payment i think you
just got to remember it's only a
small fund and 150 pounds that's just
under 950
households any other questions
i have one myself uh and i think
probably for you andrew um do we where
where we have tenanted uh properties not
not dials necessary but private um
private rented properties
do we know how many of those where the
landlord pays the council tax as opposed
to the tenant
thank you i don't at this moment in time
we did the extracts on saturday and
they're just being um filtered so it's
something i can circulate after an event
how many we won't be paying because
it's a landlord that's liable
thank you thanks
right um councillor mclaren you have a
question thank you chair
um
interesting interesting report
um we had a conversation at audit and
standards the other day
about the accuracy of
registrations for council tax
and
my question is how can we be sure that
every house
in vance a and d
are the primary
are the primary residents because that's
what it says in the report the primary
resident because one or two of us have
got concerns about
perhaps registrations that are not
entirely accurate
thank you
thank you um
i guess we
what have we match our data with
electoral register
and with those that pay by direct debit
we're going to pay the 150 pound after
we've claimed the first direct debit
for the non-direct debit cases there is
some post payment insurance work that
we're doing with the government around
data matching
to ensure that our records match
other records that have that liable
person
so
continue with that
um
what if a house is registered as a main
residence
so they're for entitled to this
but actually is a holiday home
again it will all depend on
our records what we have and then what
comes from data matching um because we
don't have
access to
data from other areas
which is why the government has done
this post payment insurance where
they'll look at um
i guess bank accounts that are paid
across the whole of the country to see
whether they've been multiple payments
but fundamentally you know it is based
on what customers tell us and whether we
match
other records internally such as
electoral register so if somebody's
registered to vote there and they're
registered on council tax and they're
paying the full charge
then that's who we have as the liable
person
so how how as a district councillor or
any other district councillor could who
would we raise any concerns we had that
we thought we knew of
some discrepancy
send them through to me and then we can
put them through to the corporate
governance team to
look at it
thank you chair yeah thank you
right if there's no further questions
we'll move into debate um members of the
cabinet council arthi
go back chairman to what i was talking
about earlier on um which is the
recommendations and the two options
where um recommendation 3.1 seems to go
for option one
um
there are two things that i'd like to
say about it really one is to give a
little bit of more i'd like us as a
cabinet to give a little steer to andrew
about where we ought to go with the
discretionary scheme
um and you mentioned it in your question
and that is my concern that we've got
people
who are in need of the energy rebate
because they are the ones that pay the
energy bill
but they're not the council tax payer
and i think that this discretionary
payment should be going to those people
who are in need from an energy point of
view but may not be the council taxpayer
and i've spoken to you about this before
and i think you've confirmed that
the landlord probably wouldn't be
eligible depending on what status the
landlord has
but even if they are
it's aimed at the energy pay and not not
at the landlord so
um what i'd like to see happen is that
you work up a scheme it'll take a while
i know you've told me that work up
scheme um for identifying um and paying
and being able to pay out
an element it obviously wouldn't be the
full 150 pounds i don't think but if we
could use all of that um discretionary
payment um perhaps it would have to be
done by application because i don't know
if you've actually got all of that
information but we could invite
applications for people who are the
energy player but not the
couch taxpayer and i would like that
proposal chairman to come back to us as
a cabinet for approval so i think
that would be
a change to 3.1
to have option two
for the discretionary payments
do i need to propose that as an
amendment yes
i propose that
may i have a seconder for the amendment
councillor osborne
councilwoman do you wish to say anything
no i think councillor arthur said it all
really so at the risk of not repeating
it i can completely concur with what he
said and have the same concerns if we
were to go with the um suggested options
so no i completely support option two
does anyone else wish to
comment during the councillor barrett
well i mean i don't have a problem with
the proposal and the second but
it just means that it delays it possibly
for a month as it's going to then wait
to come back to cabinet
and whereas really this wants to be
getting out to people
and i think this is the this is the
whole problem with this this is like do
we really do if we if if counselor
arthur has made a quite a good steer
which i'm sure that the
um
mr cap
wilcox will take on board
i don't think we really do need to have
it come back for us to approve if we've
already given the steer
that's just strikes me as it because it
could delay the distribution of the
money would that be correct andrew
yeah depending on when it when it comes
back it could
delay but it'll be useful to get steer
of the types and now i can circulate a
draft
policy that helps
counsel a hold
yeah i mean we've got a very reminder
142 000 pounds in total
i think the paper
148 i mean
i think we've got to be very careful we
don't over
over commit too much time
to this i mean it could take
considerable time
if we go into too much detail of
requirements but fundamentally we want
that 142 000 pounds to go to the most
needy whether they are council taxpayers
or not um
i just don't want to overburden officers
with a complicated
view that could take a long time to sort
out i don't think anything's going to be
100
right
i think we're going to have to just
fly by the seat of a pants we want to
put a better phrase and do what we can
the best that we can the main thing is
to get 150 pounds
payments out as quickly as possible
but
the you know who pays the direct debits
the tenants they're all very valid
points and if we can put that 142 000
pounds to it 148 to address that
fantastic but i don't think we need to
overburden officers
with too much
okay um before council of our comes back
i believe the monitoring officer wishes
to say something
thank you chair um just from a technical
perspective um the amendment that
councillor arsey has proposed is not
actually an amendment
um because an amendment has to be
specifically to add or remove wording
whereas what you're you're suggesting is
actually to replace the recommendation
with option two instead of option one
so it can't be an amendment just to
change the option i think there are two
ways that you could potentially achieve
what you're trying to achieve which is
either to vote against
the recommendation that's been
put which then would force the the mata
to come back to cabinet or you could
amend the wording to say rather than
saying in consultation with the cabinet
member for finance to say in
consultation with the cabinet and
therefore all cabinet members would be
consulted with before the discretionary
policy is finalized by officers
thank you chair thank you emily that
sounds like an eminently sensible yes
i'll go with the second one of those
thanks brian councillor barrett do you
have a comment
um
well
i think we are over complicating which
something there because within the
original 3.1 it is in it is in response
that the cabinet member finance degree
the discretion council tax energy policy
with the director assistant director so
all we're doing is that i report to you
as the cabinet
and then you say oh yeah that's all
right and then we go back i mean it does
strike me as being a little bit
i mean if either either you have a
cabinet member finance that you're happy
with
and and i've taken the steer from the
cabinet
um which i can then make sure that that
is sort of put forward
uh
do we do we feel that that's not the
case i mean i'm happy to go either way
but just right being a little bit
bureaucratic here to actually achieve
what we know we want to achieve
i think the message is quite clear so i
think we um
i would just make that point
thank you councillor holt
i tend to agree i think if if we were to
be presented as cabinet members with
with the way forward i don't think we
need a football cabinet meeting to
endorse that way forward i think we
should be able to do that uh without a
full cabinet meeting it'll be a lot
quicker
and i think the quicker we get this done
the better so i'm all for
a scheme being put back to us
informally so that we can give a steer
to the cabinet member for finance who
can then finally give you the the okay
to do it but i think we're just putting
too many layers and laying layers down
and the quicker we get it done the
better i i think just we're just
overthinking it
thank you council hall does anyone else
wish to comment
casarathi
yeah i'm happy to accept that um as as
long as
um
the cabinet member responsible um
accepts
and um acts according to the steer
um
i don't
i don't want to
bring up what's happened in the past but
i do remember that we had a similar
situation at cabinet last year um and um
the the cabinet member didn't fully
implement the steer from cabinets so um
as long as we can be sure from
councillor barrett um that he knows the
direction of travel that we're expecting
this discretionary payment to go
then i'm happy to leave it in his
capable hands and therefore would you
withdraw your amendment
um it's not an amendment because
apparently although we have two options
in our paper we don't have an option at
all
so
it wasn't an
amendment we still have something that
was uh proposed and seconded yeah
yes
um so
um yes i'll withdraw that thank you very
we have the undertaking from the cabinet
member responsible
and councillor he
do you wish to say anything yeah i i do
i i take fully on board what uh
councillor arthur says that i i there's
not a mention of parking in this
at all so clearly we haven't got
anything that we can
weave a different road i think the the
message is very clear i'm sure the
assistant director for
uh andrew will make sure that the
recommendations coming for us are as
we have stated and given the steer for
and if they aren't i will redirect him
to make sure that they are because i
think there is nothing controversial
about this it's just about getting the
money out as quick as we can to the
people that are in need of it
castle osborne and then council hall
yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah i'm
happy to accept the withdrawal of the
original recommendation that i seconded
and emily's um recommendation to a
suggestion to us and it's absolutely
right we do need to get this money out
without any delay but i know andrew is
an officer for the shared revenue
partnership
he will make sure that there's no delay
in this he will keep it as uncomplicated
as possible and he is there to help
those people get at that payment as soon
as possible and that's exactly how he
works so i'm absolutely confident that
that will happen but thank you mr
chairman thank you council hall yeah i
just want to clarify that the uh officer
will bring forward and councillor
barrett will share with all members
prior to it being implemented so that we
have a vision of what is required and
what what is proposed
so that we can endorse it
council bower has uh ascended to that uh
he nodded
yeah just to confirm that when we get
the paper through with the deli with the
delegation on um it will be very
straightforward just to uh bring that to
the attention cabinet and uh
hopefully that you all feel comfortable
with that decision
yes
council buzzfeed did you want to say
anything
well i'm not certain what all this
obsession with speed is
this is uh uh money to go to people to
cover the increased cost of
energy
which they haven't yet consumed haven't
yet paid for
there's a danger that if we send out all
the money out now it could be spent
before the increased bills
actually hit the mats
i think
i don't think that it has to go out
as quickly as possible it needs to go
out as efficiently as possible but the
the increased bills aren't yet there a
council of barrett is itching to to to
go on this but uh i just say that um the
energy costs uh have been stuck the
rises to start at the beginning of this
month the beginning of the new tax year
um people on direct debit will start to
to feel that with their monthly direct
debit payments at the end of this month
so that they will start feeling the uh
the effect very soon but council barrack
did you want to say something yeah well
i mean this this money is i would see
that is more likely to be going to
people who are on uh prepaid meters and
uh that is where the direct debit
doesn't actually come in so and if
you're on a prepaid meter or on a a
one of those um
keys that you put into the machine then
the immediate
requirement is there because they are
paying as they go
unlike the direct debit uh requirement
so there's
are possibly the people that would be in
need straight away because they are
feeling it now
as their prepaid meter uh the amount if
you put 10 pounds on
you get a lot less energy for your 10
pounds than you do hence there is a
requirement for those people to be
identified quickly if you're on direct
debit it's not as you say it's not quite
such an issue but um a lot of the people
that we're targeting this at will be
people on pre-paid meters
and also of course people who
will be taking oil deliveries or caller
gas deliveries in the next month or so
councilman malvisi
thank you mr chairman
this is to help the most vulnerable in
society and i think what we've not
mentioned are the the
um disabled
the sick
whose bodies cannot regulate their own
temperature so it's really important
that they get this money asap
thank you thank you
okay um
any other comments
in which case um
i was hoping we would get through a
meeting without mentioning the p word
but um
that's probably too much uh
being too optimistic but we'll now move
to the the vote on this please
thank you chair just to confirm you are
voting on recommendation 1.1 and sorry
3.1 and 3.2
as detailed in the report
and the vote is now in progress
chair that is uh eight votes four so
that is carried thank you
item 11
paper bca 2150
the vapor mid suffolk sustainable travel
vision and local cycling and walking
infrastructure plan
i'll now invite the cabinet member for
climate change biodiversity and
sustainable transport to introduce the
report councilmelvisi
thank you mr chairman
today i'm asking that you endorse the
local cycling and walking infrastructure
plan
better known as lc whip
along with a sustainable transport
vision document that's in your
background documents
endorsement is recommended so that the
lc whip can be supported and utilized as
recommended by national government
guidance
the sustainable travel vision will be
used to inform the public about our key
values aims ambitions and narrative
around sustainable travel
although the lc whip will be made public
its key functions are to inform sc
suffolk county highways
and our own planning department
of our active travel infrastructure
ambitions in order to capture
opportunities for delivery
this body of work stems from the
national government strategy on
sustainable travel
and its findings came about through data
received from more than 1 800
consultation responses
and they were applied to technical
guidance templates
the very technical complex and detailed
work that was undertaken by catherine
davis
and hopefully assisted by a cross-party
working group
requires our thanks
thank you catherine for making sense of
all that data
the lc whip demonstrates what is needed
and where
it has helped us identify priority
routes
which will inform
suffolk county and our own planning
department
of where the need exists and how
necessary it is
the arguments are supported by the data
and this in turn will help draw down the
funding required and available
not to endorse this piece of work is to
fail our residence and to turn a deaf
ear
to
three and a half thousand people that
actually accessed the consultation
process and the eighteen hundred people
that actually committed to it
they want to be heard
it'll also deny our district the funding
to improve our times and villages
connectivity and we'll have a
detrimental impact on its growth
as a tourist offering
elsie whips set out the government's
cycling and walking investment strategy
it's a new way of identifying the
improvements required at a local level
consequently i commend this strategy and
ask that you endorse it
thank you councilman vc may have a
second to please
gasol busby
anybody from the cabinet have a question
that's arathi yeah i think i've got one
for catherine um and it's how this
ties in with and informs the county lc
whip
i was very much under the impression
that the county lc whip would
effectively comprise of
the the separate districts
elsie whips sort of all combining to
former county lc whip
but i understand that might not
necessarily be the case and there might
be some sort of work being done by
suffolk county council and if there is
could it actually end up contradicting
our lc whip
thank you thank you councillor arthi and
so that is that is the case and your
interpretation there is correct that um
suffolk county council have encouraged
all boroughs and districts to produce
their own lc whip to better enhance and
inform the beginnings of of their lc
whip so in the interim and because it
does take quite a long time to develop
an lc whip in the interim suffolk county
council pulled together some existing
data they had from a cycle policy
development panel which was a list of
schemes that they had been aware of for
cycle improvements
and they sort of put that forwards as
their lc whip um but by their own
admission it's it's not very um well
informed because it didn't have um
public consultation backing that and so
the idea of encouraging boroughs and
districts to produce their own lc whip
which they can you know merge together
to supersede that existing county-wide
lc whip as a better and more informed
and more supported evidence-based lc
whip for the whole county
yes certainly yeah
does that mean that what we're approving
will
just de facto become part of the county
lc whip or have the county got some sort
of veto
over what we produce
no there's no victory over what we
produce so
what
what we're asking you to endorse today
is our kind of starter list of schemes
that we're recommending to suffolk
county council and
you know it is the highways authority
it's a responsibility to to investigate
all those schemes further and then take
forward schemes that they feel are
feasible as and when funding is
available and so
you know the responsibility to drive it
forward still lies with them but ours
our list is is a recommendation to them
of you know
community consultation
backed evidence of where infrastructure
improvements are needed
yes
and um
so when um suffolk county council
highways let's say end up agreeing with
supporting and costing
a project that's in rlc whip
when it comes to funding
they're not
likely to have the funding i don't think
and may well then be am i right here
able to submit a sil bid to us
to help fund some of these projects
yes that can be the case um where they
are looking at different sources of
funding they may recommend a seal
application
but they'll also be in a position to
apply for national government active
travel funding and which is the the
larger tranches of funding coming down
and and essentially what the national
government guidance lays out is that
um allocations will be favorable to
authorities that have lc whips so you
know in in that sense it's um you know
providing schemes that are already
listed in an elsi whip that they can ask
for that funding for
so
i'm sorry
so so it's quite possible that some time
in the not too distant future
we will be looking at perhaps a
collaborative funding approach where um
some government funding will be
provided for the county council to
distribute on
sort of
some schemes i don't know if they're
going to prioritize them or whatever
and we will then get involved again
with additional funding presumably
through seal bids which come to this
cabinet for approval
yes that may well be the case i think a
collaborative approach is definitely
going to give us the best chance of
securing funds for for all of the
delivery
so yes collaborative approach indeed
thank you um before i go to council a
whole i just got one quick question
myself and that is
if
if we identified a scheme that we could
deliver and it wouldn't require the
county to deliver but uh fitted into
the parameters of what the lc whip is
trying to do would we be able to fund
that and and
go ahead with that ourselves without
consulting the county
i would have to double check the process
on that and we could certainly put
forward funding um and say that you know
we want this delivered but as they are
the highways authority i think it is it
is still a county council
um duty to undertake the the designing
of the schemes and sort of the
engineering of that and then they would
again take it to a hyper local
consultation and to see if it had
support before delivery so there is
quite a complex delivery process with
all active travel infrastructure schemes
that we would need suffolk county
council to help us with
but if we were presenting funding you
know we could give them a really clear
steer that we would like them to
investigate the feasibility of this
scheme that we can fund and you know if
they're designing and engineering and
consultation
makes that scheme deliverable then they
would be the ones to implement it
uh
i'm conscious i might be veering into
debate myself and breaking my own rules
on this but um the sort of thing that
i've got in mind which not really
covered in this is and this is something
that has been raised by residents near
me
is the provision of
cycle um storage and
and lock-up facilities in village
centers so that when somebody
cycles from an outlying part of the the
countryside into one of our larger
villages the core villages
and they want to go to the shop or pub
or whatever
there's nowhere to lock their bike now
that's the sort of infrastructure that
would really assist with
providing a
coherent cycling
route for them but
we wouldn't necessarily need the county
to get permission for us to do that
no that's correct so we wouldn't need um
we'd need landowner permission to
install
cycling parking facilities but not
necessarily highways permission no so
that is something that we can do
ourselves
and there was an opportunity on the
public consultation for people to feed
in where they think cycle parking is
needed so we do have some some data on
that some recommended locations for more
cycle parking that we can work through
okay um i'll
speak to you offline about that because
i've received a couple of emails on that
subject thank you councillor holt
yeah a couple of um things the 1881
people that participated was that just
solely the baber participants
that was baba and mid suffolk so both
districts were on the same consultation
map yeah okay so that wasn't just labor
and the second thing was out of suffolk
as a whole
we are the first to complete our lc whip
and how far are the county along with
theirs is it complete or are we just
ahead of the game as we usually are in
baber
so the county council elsie whip is
still in in draft form and i believe you
know that sort of an interim whilst
others produce theirs i believe we are
the furthest ahead um east suffolk
council
are
in the process of producing a cycling
walking strategy which is slightly
different to an lc whip that they may
they may reconsider how they want to
present their information
and i know that ipswich borough council
are just beginning the process for
theirs and west suffolk county
district council are in the process of
of looking at how to start theirs as
well and so
yeah we are slightly ahead of our
neighboring districts
council busby
when do we get to prioritize
the schemes
because there's no way we can afford all
of them if you total them up it comes
between 50 and 60 million pounds
you're not going to spend 50 million
pounds on on cycle rope routes we
haven't got 50 million pounds so
how do we prioritize when do we
prioritize
and uh
yeah we've got the short medium and long
term prioritization here but i guess
you're no no that's just allocating as
to how long the time can be
i want to see us pick or prioritize
amongst those
which ones are we going to do we cannot
do all 50 60 million pounds worth we
might only be able to do one of those
but certainly not all of them
and by saying that we uh
approve this
it almost implies that we approve all
the schemes well that can't be right so
i guess the question is what's the
process for for selecting and and
identifying the ones we want to go go
with and then prioritize those but um
council hulk before katherine answered
did you want to ask a question just
along similar lines really i suppose i
thought we'd do this in debate but um
the government have issued this
walk in cycling initiative and it's fed
down to the districts and
counties and and we have been ahead of
the game and we've got ours done but i i
think council of buzzbees touched on a
very um
important point that
this is this is a suggestion this is a
an indicative sort of
thought process that we've gone through
to to come up with a list of schemes
that potentially
our residents would like within the
district and council buzz was absolutely
right that to
bring them all forward is unrealistic
i think
members
and residents have to realize that as
much as this is a great aspiration of
ours
the deliverability of it is something
that is very going to be very difficult
and we are going to require government
funding to the county council to enable
us to then
sort of put our hand up and say we have
a scheme ready to go and this is what
this is all about it's having a scheme
that's been thought out to a point
um and that our residents recognize are
important to them
but it sort of puts us ahead of people
at the moment so if the funding does
come along we have something to go to
county
and say look we've got this scheme we
need it funding we need it process we
need it costed and then we may be in a
position ahead of others to get get that
money
but not all of this is going to be
delivered by any means i think the other
important thing
is that this list of schemes is a living
document it's a live document
we have gone off residents thoughts and
i know catherine's put a lot of work
into into the items on here a lot of
them were dismissed
but i think as as a council as and as
ward members
we need to look at these further
as and when they come forward because
they're not
all good
i'll bring one up later but they're not
all good um and some of them aren't that
well thought out from from um not from
the residents i mean the residents have
their wish list and they want to improve
cycling and walk and fully understand
that i think we all do as well
but we have to realize where this
document sits in the grand scheme of
things and it's not something we're
saying we're going to deliver on
there may be some things in there we can
deliver on but with government funding
there may be some things we wish to do
as an individual council
i think we should be looking at
cross-country recreational routes but
possibly more than highway routes
because that's something as a local
authority we could bring forward
so there's a lot more to this
and a lot more work required than just
what we've got here today
thank you uh catherine did you want to
pick up on the or cass rather on the uh
prioritization
selection
thank you very much so um firstly i
think just to put a bit of background on
this um you'll have seen through the
document that a cross-party um
group were put together to talk about
the prioritization and within the report
is the uh how the prioritization happens
so there were a lot a lot more schemes
put forward by the general public that
went into that group to have a look at
and that initial prioritization has been
done which is what the list is that's
before you today of course now there's
more work to go on and do so um this is
the
set of
schemes that we're putting forward
suffolk county council now we'll take a
look at that in terms of what catherine
said about the highway engineers and
looking at technically what can go ahead
and what can happen there'll be some
cost-benefit analysis to that as well in
terms of what's actually
the ability for suffolk to go ahead and
do
but just to say i think council holt's
point this is an iterative process so
this is a point in time which absolutely
it needs to be but this is going to go
up go on for you know a 10 year period
so as and when new schemes come forward
or as and when new funding comes forward
that's when more schemes will be added
to this list the same kind of
consultation will happen with local
residents and stakeholders uh our
website uh where the lc was consulted on
is still live and so there's contact
details on there for members of the
public to put new schemes on so so this
is the prioritised list that we're
asking members to um
agree with us today to go forward to
suffolk county council for that next
step but it certainly doesn't mean the
end of the journey this is something
that will continue to go forward whether
it's new funding new developments you
know there's lots of things that could
inform new schemes coming forward
thank you guys um
firstly uh
councillor dawson you had your hand up
first and then castle baron
yes i was just wondering whether um
all the
why there's any particular reason on the
first three pages why it's all sudbury
for the short and medium term
and all the long term seems to be sort
of shortly and
sprouted
um who thought of
was was there any method in the madness
of prioritizing
and yes there certainly was method and
so you'll see from the appendix of the
methodology report the prioritization
criteria matrix
that matrix was taken from the national
government's technical guidance for
developing lc whips and they actually
have an example prioritization table
that they recommend is used
now we did tweak it slightly as far as
was practically possible to
enable our more rural schemes and rural
locations um the chance to to score
highly in certain criterias
but
a lot of the scoring criteria is
recommended by um
the government methodology and also the
propensity to cycle tool which is used
as well to determine the
potential for more active travel
journeys in a place
it does
tend to
bring out higher scores for urban areas
so that is why
schemes in our larger towns have scored
more highly
than perhaps some of our schemes in
smaller villages and rural locations
but that is why we we were very keen not
to dismiss
all of our rule schemes on the basis
that they wouldn't score highly we have
still included them because we don't
know whether in the future new funding
streams will emerge that actually makes
them much more feasible so that is why
it's still worth including them on the
list
while i understand obviously that how
that scoring has come about
there is a also political dimension that
we need to to be mindful of and the fact
that um everything is skewed towards
sudbury very heavily
it might not play very well in other
parts of district if yet again we see
all of our effort and
potentially money is going into one
place only um it it um
it could cause us such problems and we
do need to be mindful of of the need to
be seen to be
baber district rather than just
focus on on sudbury
but um
councillor barrett and then councillor
halt
just just um
on the uh the list of uh
identified projects
um
one that
certainly
i've been
involved because i actually live on the
road uh biggest road melted road
um
which with the the the uh county you've
actually sent they've all started
consultation on that
and that's pretty universally being
condemned
uh because it's
it's it's not a good one
are we at this stage able to take that
out
because pretty much university that has
been accepted has not been acceptable
and it's been identified by certain
county
district councillors town council
cycle groups themselves um
i take that tim register who
uh has been auntie that um i'm sure
you've had him on the phone too
catherine yes you have you've got the
smile that's good
so
have we got that flexibility we take out
where the scheme doesn't seem to have
any benefit
so
sorry cass you're going to answer that
oh sorry i was just waiting for
permission
i was playing with my um button here
oh so rather than talk just specifically
about that if i can talk about the kind
of the rule that fits all of those
situations so um there's a number of
places that are under highway
consultation at the moment or have just
finished highway consultation and so we
mentioned about this being a snapshot in
time and things that are coming from the
public
there are definitely areas where the
highway consultation has not been
supported by local residents
and so they're going off and looking at
options as to what can be done
what we will do is look at and keep
those areas in mind in terms of we've
heard from residents that they want to
have a look at provision in that area
but of course part of our next steps is
what are highway doing in terms of their
consultation and their options so
whenever that happens
it doesn't mean it has to drop off the
list we just need to hold fire see what
happens with that consultation
if in the end that means that it does
need to come off the list then we'll do
that and we'll talk to the residents
about why that's happened or there may
be subsequent options put forward to
residents by the highway authority that
may be more um
yes more suitable for them um one thing
that i was just going to say if i can is
we spoke about methodology earlier and
there was no madness in it it was just a
good methodology um what it can be is
adapted so we have done that already
based off of the um what has been spoken
about uh centrally we've already done a
bit of that adaption if it has skewed it
in any way we can of course go back and
adapt again
thank you cass
castle osborne
thank you mrs chairman you took me out
for councillor hall was before me but
knows you are you go to us
um do we have the discretion to add to
projects and i'm going to declare a
non-pecuniary interest in this part of
my debate
um we have a a very suitable gains
betrayal that's a 15 mile walk around
sudbury and i mentioned sudbury again i
apologize for that but that's where it
is cornard and chilton and eventually
long melford that is currently a green
walk but there's nothing with funding
there would be nothing to prevent that
from being made into a cycling route as
well where people could cycle to the
outskirts of sudbury town from those
rural areas
park their bar bikes and go in and do
their shopping which is much better than
trying to put cycle routes through a
very
dangerous small market town so is there
discretion to add such a project to that
i did forward that but it hasn't it
hasn't gone into the document
yes yeah absolutely there is scope to
make additions to these lists as i say
they do remain dynamic i think um in the
example of the gains press trail we need
to bring in the rights of way team more
so than the the highways authority
because i think you know they need to
work together
um as i understand the route covers
more rights of way um than roads so i
think
the questions there about
designations um
sort of from footpaths to
where cycling is permitted and so that
that can very much be mentioned uh
within the lc whip and i can add that in
um but i think the rights of way team
will be needed to
to be brought on board with that
particular one
that's rossman do you wish
yeah thank you we are very fortunate on
the group that we actually have an
officer from county that is the public
foot pass
and yeah right of way officer so uh that
shouldn't be a problem
so we can have a discussion away from
that from this platform thank you
councillor hall
yeah a couple of things first thing you
mentioned about the disproportion of
locations and i think it's a little bit
unfair to be honest because
in the long term
plan
there's an awful lot to the east of the
district it's just that they're much
harder and more expensive to deliver
and so the mythology in producing the
plan was a scheme of short-term
medium-term and long-term projects
so i think we have to acknowledge that
it does go across the breadth of the
district it's just that some of them are
very very expensive to deliver i think
they shot the
cycle route in towards it which is a
very important one but if you do it in
the piecemeal sections that we've got on
the list you add the up as council the
busbees alluded to earlier it's an awful
lot of money that should be an
aspiration of ours to to deliver that
but we have to be able to think step
back and just think methodically and say
how achievable is it in the short term
it isn't which is why it's in a long
term project
and the other thing is um officer
mentioned about um
this council about about
the junction at melbourne road
in sudbury um
again we have to be mindful that
one person recommending one scheme
does not necessarily mean that those
residents
locally would support it
and i think you know if you take out
1800 people put in across both districts
a lot of them were one or two
individuals who mentioned a scheme that
they thought would be suitable
so again we must just run away with
these and say well that's what the
public wants because we need to rein it
back in a bit and just look at it and i
think we do need to go through our lists
in over the next few months and possibly
bring other board members in and get
more local knowledge and input from
those
so that we can perhaps filter those
through a bit more and add more schemes
to them because as we
go through the process this is
the lc whip is going to become more
prominent people are going to be more
aware of it
and when that happens you will get much
more input so i think that's why we want
this living document
to just be acknowledged put out there
and work with it add to it and take
things off yeah
thank you councilman obisi
just a point of information uh mr
chairman
there were workshops to which all
members were invited and they were
interactive
yeah thank you
council hall
i was a member of the lc whit board as
well and i would agree there were
workshops but we all know with
councillors
here today that aren't on the cabinet
they don't attend
so um
you know they can argue afterwards that
they weren't invited and involved they
were but this is why this document is
important now we get it out there it's
it's a it's a document that we endorse
and they can have their say afterwards
but
yeah we live in the world where we live
okay
i'm conscious we've kind of moved into
debate and straight into the debate
we've uh but then
it's kept the flow going quite well but
does anyone else wish to contribute
council buzzfeed yeah
it was a kind of a question and kind of
debate
are all these amounts uh reflected in
the pips the parish
infrastructure plans
um not as of yet but they certainly can
be so this can be utilized for informing
exactly that
for parish council planning for funding
for neighbourhood planning um once this
you know is shared more widely it can be
used as a tool and one thing that we
will make clear is this initial
assessment of schemes the
the costings that you see today they are
very um initial and indicative costings
um to get more accurate these are just
sort of a ballpark figure to demonstrate
to us whether a scheme is very very
expensive or not so expensive and
you know i have been working with with a
list provided by highways of a very
rough guide price of what different bits
of infrastructure cost and you know
using that to base these indicative
costs
but in order to get more accurate
costings um the highways authority and
engineers and designers would need to
look at it and provide us with more
accurate figures so
these costings are rough but as and when
schemes are looked at by highways they
can become more accurate and then
hopefully that will help with with
parish spending and pips
i have great concern over this whole
exercise i'm afraid chair um
look it's like it's like me making a
list of 50 holidays that i'd like to go
on
one of them is
a fortnight in the mouldings and the
other is 50 weekends in grimsby i mean
just because i can afford each weekend
in grimsby doesn't mean that i've got to
spend all my money on that it might be
that i want to save that money and have
a fortnight in my maldives it might be
that all of these short-term
schemes we should ditch because there's
one good one
a really good one
in the long term
without having any idea of how much
money we're going to spend on this this
is just wishful thinking it's going to
raise expectations there's a danger that
will pick the wrong ones
just because
oh this scheme's ready to go let's find
150 000. where's that coming from
i should be really cheesed off it comes
out of
some of my villages
funds that they've raised money for by
having houses for specific schemes
i think we've got to go through this and
narrow this list down and start working
out
which ones we really want and what we're
likely to be able to spend on it and i
don't think it should be down to the
engineers we shouldn't be giving them a
huge amount of work to to cost up more
accurately 50 60 70 80 schemes whatever
it is i think we're we're going about
this the wrong way i'm sorry
okay thank you counselor
castle hole
i i think
council budget's got to be aware that
the money for this is generally going to
come from central government in bits and
pieces
so the schemes that we've got on the lc
whip we will draw down on those schemes
depending on what money might be
available to us
and i think it's important we do have
the short medium long term ones
available you're not going to be able to
achieve the long-term
goals in one go
the government aren't i don't believe
going to come down with a billion quid
and say look we'll give county suffolk
county councils have been included to
achieve all their lc whip aims because
that's not going to happen
so they might the county might end up
with half a million quid and and us and
the other three districts in the borough
council all might be going for that so
we have to be realistic on what money
might be available there may be other
ways that we can top that money up via
the seal program which has been
mentioned already
but we're going to match fund or we've
got to try and match fund what the
government may put our way
the importance of this the importance of
this
policy is that we have schemes in there
that are short medium long term that
aren't ready to go but we're ready to
pitch for
but it's important that we go into those
schemes from now on
to nail down
what
local board members want because it will
change
this is not a finished scheme list of
schemes
i think it's important that we pass the
document today
but note that the list of schemes in
this paper
is not something as a cabinet we're
endorsing every single one because we're
not we're endorsing the principle of the
paper we're leaving it up to the ads to
come back and vet those schemes
as and when they get into consultation
with the districts of sorry districts
parish councils and town councils
the importance is we've got the policy
in place the detail which i admit is in
there now is fluid it will change we can
put in we can take out but i think the
importance of the scheme is the key
thing here and as i say i will be
supporting it but i would stress that
we're not necessarily endorsing every
single scheme in there is something we
want or think our residents want us to
deliver
thank you council hull uh i agree with
that um certainly they're one or two
that um
we can all identify schemes here that we
would uh
like to comment on see changes to or um
add to take away um i personally have
have got some concerns about what's been
said about the 1871 at um boxer between
cali street sand hill um
in terms of what what we can do there
it's it talks about a very expensive
scheme carriageway improvements but uh
about 270 000 pounds but there must be
something that can improve the
connectivity from one side of the a-1071
to the other
between cali street sandhill and going
further down to
stone street
to improve the connectivity across the
road um for
for pedestrians and cyclists
but um i think we probably all had a
good
a good go at this and council mclaren
did you want to say ask a question thank
you chair i would welcome that
um
catherine
um
the paper's comprehensive i'm really
speaking on behalf of shortly peninsula
two of my cabinet colleagues are not
here so i'm speaking for the whole of
the peninsula
um
and so the pay and i i think as a group
of communities i think shockley
peninsula would be very much for active
walking and cycling but looking through
the report
and i'm not sure whether it should be in
there but i'm going to raise it is the
aspect of schools
and can i just elaborate on that i know
it's not good i was going to ask you the
question
um in in the peninsula we have a
shortage of primary school places
so you can get a mother driving to three
different schools with three different
children
we have got an academy and we've got two
private schools where
mothers drive in their children every
day from as far as framingham and felix
stowe in whatever mode of transport they
use
and so my question is about
has the county council or has
uh lc whit
locally considered this problem because
we'd like to see children walking to
school and children cycling to school
has that been our schools being
considered in this paper
thank you councillor yes yes school
access has been considered so
one of our prioritization criteria
was about the
benefit of the intervention for a
particular user group and that included
access to schools and all places of
education actually
chair thank you
while reading the long-term aspiration
for shortly
i am disappointed and any members of the
public reading this public document
which is out on
online i'm sure they're disappointed
with it as well that the long aspiration
for the shockley
peninsula
every weekend chocolate peninsula
welcomes hundreds of cyclists especially
during the summer
it's advertised as
a center for cycling if you go on the
tourist
information
and so
i'm just asking about the thing you know
shortly has lost a lot of business over
through the pandemic
and we need all the tourists we can uh
accommodate on shortly
can you explain why shortly perhaps is a
long aspiration rather than a short
aspiration thank you
thank you
so um
as you um have alluded to there's
there's an awful lot of passion and
desire for better cycling and walking
routes in shortly and that was very much
reflected all over our public
consultation and there were comments all
over it just for general better
connectivity
so looking at that and the desire lines
that came through our public
consultation we split the shortly routes
into sections um
and even splitting them unfortunately
they are expensive schemes the
connectivity between villages
but
what we have done actually is split it
um in sections going
in various directions and actually if
you look at the short term list
the shortly
the the section of the shotley peninsula
on freston hill so that that the first
connection bit that has um been
prioritized as a short-term aspiration
and then
you know
in time if that is delivered
then it adjusts the scores of the other
sections of the route because there's
some criteria there linked to
whether the schemes you know fix a
standalone project or actually a
standalone issue in connectivity or
whether they open up a gateway for more
improvements to make a longer
route so if we see delivery on preston
hill um and you know this this lc whip
has already
sparked some conversations between
the shotley peninsula cycling campaign
and myself and county highways and the
seal team so we are really looking to
progress that scheme
if there is delivery there then it makes
the next section of route more viable
and then we can adjust the scores of
that one and that may then
be sort of
changed from a longer term to a more
medium or shorter term
ambition and we can keep adjusting as
more bits get delivered
but really you know when looking at such
a long connectivity room we need to
start somewhere and that's why that
freston hill section which is sort of
the key gateway area has been
prioritized as a short-term priority in
the hope that delivering something there
will enable
the rest of the connectivity on shortly
peninsula to be
and brought up the priority list
yes i think that's helpful actually
catherine
because anybody that drives on shortly
peninsula on a sunday it is in fact
freston hill
that is the major
i often i go to holbrook every sunday
and i'm usually behind 20 cyclists going
at preston hill so we welcome that but
can i just ask that that is well
publicized when when we whatever the
time span is or whenever it's agreed
because people will understand that and
welcome that and probably give them
patience for the rest of
the cycleways that are proposed for
shortly thank you very much thank you
chairman thank you customer clarence um
uh councillor arthy did you then
councillor busby yeah just just a quick
one um and funnily enough it's about
councillor buzzfeed i hope to get a
holiday postcard from him and i hope it
comes from greensbee and not from the
maldives
um but what i really wanted to pick up
on was um something that councilman
mclaren has said about safe routes to
schools
and yes these will be picked up and
thank you to catherine who's picked up
the one in cockfield um where there's a
break in the footwear provision um to to
the school
so i'm looking forward thank you for
picking it up and thank you for all the
rest of your work because i have to say
catherine's done a
sparkling job on it thank you
cancer buzzing
well can i just i can confirm to clive
arthy that uh of course it will be
grimmers because we're on baber
allowance it's not mid suffolk
allowances
i look i have a problem
having seconded this
report i was happy to second the actual
documents but i'm not happy if that is
the inclusion of all of the schemes so
you might need to
find another second i think
okay
well i'll um second then
um if if nobody has any further
contribution um i think we've had a good
a good go at this we've been um but we
have focused admittedly on the schemes
rather than the uh the bodies of the two
reports not just the lc work but also
the sustainable travel vision which
we've got here um i think as as two
reports though um irrespective of the
merits or otherwise of individual
schemes which clearly
there's more work more um discussion and
and more consultation um that the
reports are are excellent and uh and i'd
like to endorse um my colleagues and
thanking you catherine for the work that
you've put in and also for um
your contribution uh this afternoon in
terms of answering questions i think
that's been very helpful for us and
helpful for us
in order to understand and to ensure
we've had a good discussion and debate
about this
councillor holt then
i'll leave
the last word to you before we go to the
vote i i just want to confirm earlier on
i did say that as a cabinet we weren't
in uh supporters or endorsing all the
list of schemes
so i just want to make sure that that is
clear i can't see in the recommendation
that we're actually approving all the
schemes so i just want to make that
point clear this is to approve the lc
whip document not the schemes in the
document
councilman vc sorry i didn't realize you
you wanted to
yeah thank you very much
um just to
further confirm what councillor holt has
said and to allay the fears that
councillor busby might have um we are
not agreeing the schemes
we are endorsing the strategy
the schemes have picked up
recommendations at cabinet briefing
and i know that catherine's been working
on those recommend on those issues that
were raised
and i'm sure there might have been
issues raised with mid-suffolk this
morning and catherine will be working it
is a living document
that will change over time
yeah thank you castlemore bc and just to
remind members
we
the recommendation is to
endorse the draft documents
um and at the completion of the final
documents delegated to the ad for
economic development in consultation
with the portfolio holder
for
climate change biodiversity sustainable
transport
okay um
i think it's time we moved to the vote
then
everyone happy with that we'll go to the
vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is uh seven votes
for and uh one vote against
thank you
that concludes today's meeting everyone
um the
next meeting is on monday the 9th of may
at 2pm please note that the agenda
pack is incorrect i'll say saturday the
9th of may i'm sure none of you wants to
be here on a saturday
okay
no definitely monday the night for me
okay
thank you well